non mais à la fin ils m'envoient c'est
un et moi j'ai dit stop
ouais mais je comprends pas je comprends
même temps il était à collants il est
alors nommé ce jour c'est un voisin des
gens comme ça j'aurais pu un peu creusé
à creuser mais ce tag a permis quatre
chômeurs mais les riches [ __ ] pardon
je suis désolé pardon je m'en excuse moi
tiens regarde juste pour me faire
pardonner
j'ai moi aussi ah ouais
j'ai pas bu depuis j'essaye d'avoir un
enfant moi comme ça fait dix neuf mois
ou semaines parce que je viens
d'apprendre qu'au choix de vimont mais
des ruthénois sa gloire est à la base
était pas le moment de parler de ton
était récemment mais en fait ça dérange
pas du tout moi je suis dans un stade où
là j'adore parler l'utérus chanter
nicolas habas enchanté charlotte prague
est ok bon bah j'espère que ça va
s'arranger quand même plus du tout envie
que ça s'arrange tu vois je me plie dans
tous les sens depuis un an pour elle
j'essaye de faire en sorte que tout se
passe bien aller jamais contente donc
c'est l'horreur meilleurs contrats en
tout cas là n'était pas content je suis
désolé des filles je vous souhaite une
bonne journée je vous demande pardon
vraiment c'est quoi en fait enlève ton
t-shirt taton il est haché retire ton
tee shirt c'est je le prends je l'emmène
au pressing tu arriveras jamais nettoyer
toutes ces tâches tout seul c'est pas
pour ce big c va être là pas une tête de
femme d'intérieur savoyards n'ont
marraine qu'est ce que tu fais la
vidange pas du tout déjà su super g
n'est donc ils vont s'en fout il goûte
email va coûter 20 balles ce t-shirt
habitent loin non non j'habite juste la
première rue à voilà un tee shirt c'est
un tee shirt je te le ramène n'y a pas
de souci je regarde pas si je sais
qu'ils deviennent
oh
voilà je parle t'on 0,6 à nombre dans le
temps tu veux je te fuis pas menotté
c'est juste parce que je vais récupérer
ma veste
06 18 00 85 38
ensuite j'ai jamais vu un truc pareil
t'es pas farouche en fait je le nettoie
hockey bonne journée je suis désolé bon
ok vas salut à la maip l'est mois lui la
wii nous suivrions le peut si
indifférent mais devint il appelle
cheveux soient pas dans le coton this
way puis donnent tous les mérites est
une [ __ ] à poil vous avez le choix
[Musique]
et
vas-y tu me diras tu me racontes rien
les dix mois jamais maintenant j'ai vu
une vague noire magazine j'étais en
train de travailler les gens que je
regardais mes photos très contente de
moi et là ils m'appellent je reviens
maintenant
ouais non évidemment attendre ajoute et
il commence à décrire conçu billets y
aller trouvez vous habitez dans un clip
évidemment que j'ai flippé
et puis j'ai sorti ils étaient deux ans
il avait installé une table avec du
champagne manor pas lavé par an passé
pas impacter pressing désolé pas grave
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais attention je ne suis pas laissée il
a ramé 1 si madame veut bien se donner
la peine de ce soir je suis désolé en
fait j'ai plein de trucs à faire j'ai
pas poiret star est là il est 19 heures
tu es encore en pyjama et alors je sais
pas mais à part tes pieds la moustache
et par les touches avec ta copine qui a
plus d'utérus j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils soient débordés ils ont
franchement magnifique
non je ne sais pas c'est pas mal je suis
pas au chômage ah ouais tu fais quoi
ben je suis entre deux boulots mais je
suis pas au chômage d'accord donc ça
s'appelle le chômage nom il s'appelle 20
la wii mais avant je travaillais dans
l'arrêté juristes et puis maintenant je
me lance dans la photo d'accord voilà
est donc en fait on a commencé à boire
du champagne et toi tu fais quoi
comme rien des apparts tu fais ça que
des vieilles à sabots breath away
ah mais moi je suis commercial j'ai
gagné 1000 euros par mois mais je me
fais chier à mourir d'accord et donc tu
mets d'étape pliant devant chez les gens
à non non non attends ça c'est la
première fois c'est parce que tu
m'inspires
c'est vraiment magnifique c'est
hallucinant c'est s'émeut le font en
fait oui ensuite assise abba partie
roman je me rappelle plus rond black out
voici je suis pas hyper en forme si je
suis pas hyper drôle surtout que les
blagues c'est peut-être parce que tu me
déstabiliser toi y'a peut-être cette
possibilité d'être d'habitude fait rire
que les boudins directes at il enfin
tarzan jusqu'ici été complètement
ghislaine lesca s'avance quatre mois
chez moi non mais je suis pas à 100 je
veux juste dormir etc toiles sont les a
jamais couché avec une meuf qui portent
des pulls d'enfants séparés où il a
conclu un an j'ai joué j'ai déjà comment
ça va se passer
voici ma la fournisseurs tp tu va tout
détruire tromper mais je crains
tellement gros que je te pardonnerai
toiture qu'on mangera encore une encore
puisque j'anticipe lui oui toi l avant
avec avec la bienvenue en bas
non mais il réagit qu'il n'a pas
forcément il n'a pas forcément envie de
d'insister tu vas mais moi j'y crois et
je me dis que ça va ça va faut juste
qu'on persiste à un tout petit peu c'est
tout mais oui mais oui je sais tu es
magnifique dans le reste j'ai comme ça
te fait ressortir le beurre mais attend
et regarde légèrement
[Musique]
tu vois que il faudrait que je change la
typo
un architecte mais leur dépendance et
comment ce jeu c'est la première fois
que l'actrice couche avec une nana du
tout il suffit
la photo de mon expo j'adore c'est la
saignée les premières photos pourtant
l'ex fois la parole l'affiché moche tu
dis qu'elle est moche c'est quoi la
photo c'est quoi c'est la photographie
secrète
qu'est ce qu'un parfum que j'en sors ça
pour quelqu'un
c'est un truc hyper étrange heures à
beyrouth
oui c'est pas ça s'apparente à du mépris
[Musique]
alors ça c'est une photo qui m'intéresse
là tu vas te [ __ ] ça te parle
[Musique]
s'il lâche ton téléphone je comprends
pas ça fait trois jours par un message
rien n'est même pas un like sur facebook
- non mais attends c'est normal entre 8
et 10 quitter mais [ __ ] tu as dit tous
les spas et rocco pas non non il m'a pas
dit qu'il m'aimait il m'a dit qu'il
avait eu le coup de foudre et excuse moi
c'est vrai que c'est pas du tout les
mêmes choses n'ont pas à manger ni boire
qu'est ce que je fais je l'appelle mais
oui qu'est ce que tu as à perdre
au pire il sera avec une meuf voilà en
quoi une meuf elle n'était pas avec lui
et a le droit non oui oui c'est vrai moi
de venir vous fait pas très fin en fait
tu es
pourquoi vous êtes ici